so the quantum materials program you
know started almost 30 years ago and the
reason why it's been so successful over
the years is that it it brought together
three types of experts that are
essential for making discoveries in our
field in the field of materials the sea
far quantum materials program has a very
long history of bringing together three
different groups of people those who
synthesize new new materials those
who've conduct cutting-edge physics
experiments on them and theorists who
develop new mathematical models of these
types of quantum behaviors so we're
going way back we had the Stone Age and
then you know the Bronze Age and the
Iron Age and we're living for the last
three generations we've been living in
the silicon age we are now at the dawn
of a new age called the quantum age and
this is an age where we will see a new
kind of technology called quantum
technology there's a huge variety of
different sorts of quantum technologies
that are exist or are being contemplated
you know the most direct quantum
technology in some sense that maximally
utilizes the quantumness of materials is
quantum computing yes the key was really
to bring these three different kinds of
experts in the materials experts and the
theorists and experimentalists to do
this across the planet but the other
thing of course is that it's an
interdisciplinary exercise and and
that's what c4 can do it can allow you
to bring communities to the other that
don't meet naturally so I'm extremely
excited
[Music]